[Music]
and r.i.p my wallet news oh alright P
submitted by love from New York hi Neil
live from New York it's a came use live
love love from New York yeah nah [ __ ]
that is our lay don't offend the gangs
around here
Westside experts discuss why it's so
hard to buy just one thing that target
the experts discussed this at a
roundtable no like no we know
yeah with clipboard well you see when
you go in the toilet paper aisle they
put the makeup right next to it you
always gotta buy some nylon I just
target every store true I just leave
with all these extra things that I think
I mean when they have multiple good
actually
like every time target I feel like a
blackout and then I'm out later on with
like three hundred dollars worth of
garbage you can't spend less than $300
at a target possible that's why I stay
the hell away mm-hmm it has a name what
is it called the target effect effect
oh my juicy supple lips got in the way
Filipino it's targeted oh you've ever
looked at well I'm not you have a target
at that time yeah
saying that Joe's working getting antsy
it's the move I've been sitting away do
you do that thing where you put your
your hand and your shirt like this like
the kids do did you ever do the one were
you you produce yeah and it's even
though I knew I worked like wow
every time you could talk Vidyalayas
long-sleeve yeah well you pie away but
you make the noise but if you like you
get it wrong the first time I went like
this I actually hit I don't think I did
that's you on your head my dad when we
were kids and he'd want to yell at us
he'd go like that Sheamus back when we
were little my sister and I oh no let's
go I'm gonna be like idiot
three-year-old away it's stupid I never
did the fake whatever this called Costco
Rowan I don't know I said oh you got
stupid no my mom be like government 39
wait tormento Chino government 30 nights
of my uncle Michaela does that me
torment the Chinese no Chinese torture
yeah
my monitors to hit me with this all time
as a kid bull my head get all these
[ __ ] lumps all [ __ ] hurt you know
what's funny like I thought it was it
was weird how like moms would do this
kind of different techniques with their
hands yeah I started learning that in
karate and I was like oh my god oh [ __ ]
strikes like this oh yeah yeah they was
like that's some ridiculous yeah feels
like you're wanna flip someone I
actually oh yeah I forgot I can fight
like girl doesn't want to cuss flip you
man I always looked off with the pinkie
yeah I went like this like it's not the
one you think I could do it anyway with
the Freak my mom would still kicked my
ass cuz she it's like the intent yeah
okay I know what the fuck'd meant that
[ __ ] one time I like my mom turned
around and I ran out of a gonna wait and
she's like I saw that oh she's magic
there was a mirror my mouth noises like
a mafia she's like I'll rip it off
there's a video of it she's like this
black mom in the front seat of her car
and she has her selfie camera she's
videoing and the kid behind her doesn't
realize it he goes
she was kids holding his mom's phone and
he's recording himself there at church
and he's like why is it so loud in here
and it's so loud and yet it's like a
flip-top Hey
[Laughter]
that's all you need a little oh [ __ ] all
right
oh you're laughing at child abuse that's
not funny I think that one was abused I
think that was just snap back it's
missing a little smack yeah just a
little I used to get flipped on my oh my
mouth oh that's your cheek girlfriend or
whatever mention well nose like my mouth
like near my mouth oh right here and now
you're like what Steve does it yeah you
like that you said you don't like to be
respected I don't but that's what just
hurts that's weird you can't do that in
the middle section yeah I like what do
you like covers my mouth spring is like
shut up oh yeah yeah yeah you know I
think you and I get along fellas yes
they get along - they like was being
important oh really
yeah like we just want to be
disrespected yeah like don't respect I
mean joke it's fun - yeah yeah right see
her she get I'm mad about that Chuck oh
you think that's like joke you're like
oh really no yeah yeah there you go
last time I got choked I busted a
[ __ ] blog opinion Tiffany's listening
to interesting stories I forgot they
were here no I'm just like taking it all
in like that's what girls talk about I
knew it I [ __ ] knew it they [ __ ]
talk about periods their vaginas their
sex life every time we make fun of it
you go no we don't do that
oh yes you key word you make fun of it
we're not we're just if you approach it
normally then we'll talk about it yeah
exactly
but I knew I was right that's all I'm
saying case in point anyway back to
target here no she's one of the experts
say about the third get the face yeah
what are the expert like Walmart [ __ ]
people
there's things
well yeah Walmart is mentioned here too
so Walmart was once famous for doing
things like putting band-aids near the
fishing hooks and like things like you
would associate so so say you wouldn't
necessary Marcia but then once you see
them together you're like oh I see yeah
you good cut I do that one Marlin thing
and the hook went from under my fingers
into my nail that's mother nature dude
wait don't go fishing don't kill me
mother nature's a cool brother I thought
you're calling her stupid I think you
try to do I to a fish what the fish did
it to you I don't understand the condoms
and shaving cream Isle needs you want a
shade you want to [ __ ] you want to you
need a good to [ __ ] some stores are like
that but some stores it's the condoms
are next to the tampons
oh yeah the pad or the diapers oh yeah I
think they had it no baby and I think
they had to move it cuz they were like
why is this [ __ ] selling it's to remind
you not to do it again yeah did you guys
know that Costco purposely never puts
things like signs where everything is so
you're forced to walk around to look
around because there's no sign says oh
this aisle I know I [ __ ] hate them
and it's food samples everywhere so
you're like wow I gotta go check out
that I have a gun a Costco no don't
because there's so many goddamn Chinese
people in there man go to the other one
and there's still more Chinese people
over there no you got to go to the one
that don't have them call it that giant
fridge I like walking into class today
oh the ag-1
don't one with all the vegetables yeah
that's really cold it's like constantly
freezing last time I went there I saw a
[ __ ] Chinese leaning a PT Cruiser
backed up into a row of San Gabriel oh
yeah that's it mm-hmm yeah that's
experts here they're saying like target
is a genius when it comes to marketing
their project products especially in
their store because they make it
everything seems so like nice and like
vibrant and colorful if you notice
there's
right every every like they have great
lighting every aisle that you go to is
just popping of color the HomeGoods
the only makeup session that's the best
one to their saying whenever it's like
the home good section they actually
dress it up like what if yeah you're
right because I'm like I never knew I
wanted so many pillows but now I need
them all the time I was sad at Target
when I worked there no no than that
[ __ ] dog could be hey next time
remind me like if I'm sad and I'm like
oh something happened
take me to Target I'm not gonna buy [ __ ]
I can't go in there because people gonna
think I'm a pedophile well now you have
my anti cos oh we gotta take all the
Chuck E Cheese out eating pizza maybe
yeah even the makeup is back to its back
little target to open late so really so
then I'll go there and I'll just hang
out and I'll feel better cuz every time
I'm in there I guess something dope I
guess ding dongs yeah I get a beanbag
couch I get some kind of [ __ ] toy for
my nephew yeah can I get a bag of chips
I can spend so much time in target team
yeah looks games yeah everything good
taste oh that's another reason to the
fact that they have everything you want
they're like yeah I'm bound to come out
with everything you feel like but it's
the Equality stuff too it's not the
Walmart stuff you know Steve will not go
into malls that don't have targets
attached to them he's caused them shitty
malls so he whenever I'm like I'm going
to the mall he's like are you gonna
shitty ball are you going to the real
mall name which mall has a target which
one wet side to pain they all the
Westfield Mall
Santa Anita 1 yes and he does have a
target the one in heaven now the one in
Burbank the that's all the gallery
Valley malls yeah the one with the IKEA
Target makes me feel too bougie mhm well
they really up their game over the past
decade mm-hmm
yeah and then so apparently they're
saying that the company is trying to
revamp over 1,000 locations by the end
of 2020 any modern flourish yeah we've
[ __ ]
we're so logic 62 yeah yeah
they have this project 62 that okay you
know how like mid-century modern
furniture Zinn I don't know you know
yeah okay so that's like on all over
Pinterest is like mid-century modern and
west-allen like has all the stuff and it
costs like a [ __ ] fortune to get a
little plant stand or whatever will
target house this new of nice town like
a commercial target has this project 62
that's like all mid-century modern so
I've seen it and it's so [ __ ] cute
and it's so affordable how do you not
spend $200 when you go in there i sat
there and i steering in a lamp for like
45 minutes wondering if I wanted it it
was a nice lamp
do you put it on the floor do you like
imagine it in your room and then you
like then you put it up and you're like
mm-hmm
there's stuffs nice dude girl's gonna
shop forever forever I know I hate
shopping but I find myself like for
hours yes I think the [ __ ] have [ __ ] to
do I go in there like a broom like all I
need a new broom and then just everybody
target I can go hey babe just wait in
the car I'll be on his team in less than
10 minutes man I mean Jessica that's how
I have to send Stephen with a list and
he's good about dualist
because he's scared of getting in
trouble if he could be strays off the
list before I go in there with the list
down shop
first part two because they have that
bullseye playground that they call right
near the entrance flash exit they have a
deal with the DA like not just kind of
thinking yeah yeah you're just like I
need to buy immediately because it just
caught it in your mind you trust that
it's really cheap so you end up walking
out with the last product you like
justify it there's that go crazy amount
I call the GI goes into it target does
yeah I feel so used and just like they
studied me y'all have bad discipline
because that's and mad hours in there
but I just look around said the guy with
[ __ ] capes oh yeah we have so much
stiffer you discipline oh yeah look at
all this [ __ ] that's in front of him
[Laughter]
[Music]